[Applaudissements]
on va jouer c'est très beau les deux là
on va jouer à qui tu connais le mieux
l'autre dans les courants il ya une
photo mystère et un numéro de téléphone
cacher sa droite la photo et le numéro
de michael ou la photo de nu mairie
divers dans les corps encore d'inquiéter
passe pas mais bon on embrasse embrasse
toutes les rona dans l'écran dans les
romans dans les corps en moi tu va pas
tarder à me faire chier mais ce que je
veux te pousser à bout de ceux qui
commettent laboulaye donc il ya une
photo mystère et sa mort est vrai que
j'adore aussi quand il vient je suis
agité imagine que c'est vrai alors il a
peut être la photo et numéros de michael
ou la photo et le numéro de josy je vous
posais tour à tour des questions
l'un sur l'autre si vous répondez bien
rien ne se passe si vous répondez mal
deux chiffres du numéro de téléphone
deviendront daury donc c'est toi qui
leur a filé idée de 500 tonnes de co2
directement ça si les faits qu'à la fin
du jeu ces chiffres seront découverts et
on verra s'il s'agit de la tête de
michaël et son numéro s'il s'agit du
visage demain soit le même que c'est un
numéro facile je sais et c'est ça fait
très bon voila il m'a coûté même de
l'argent je sais ça fait très longtemps
que tu là josé la première question est
pour vous en 2001 si on joue pas au jeu
à bachelet sera à vous de trancher
[Rires]
parce que j'en fais de ton cas nolan on
va être très bonne cela en 2001
connaissent la connaît en 2000 alors
qu'elle cérémonie at on peut voir
michaël youn se déshabiller finir austry
facile ces essais qui répond c'est toi
c'est moi
ouais en 2001
faut pas qu'il faut pas qu'ils jouent
attention c'est telle cérémonie
césar mais n'ont été les 7 d'or
et ouais à les 7 d'or est vrai en 2001
dit qu'elle avait parié avec daphné
roulier de canal+ qu'il se mettrait nu
pendant la cérémonie des 7 d'or et bien
sûr il en a profité pour créer morning
live moi je m'en rappelle gt gt dans la
salle et et je le connaissais pas à
l'époque monsieur qui fait le kif et
ouais détient 7 d'or en 2001 vous avez
eu d'ailleurs une raideur j'avais un 7
d'or de quoi pour lui matin c'était le
dernier animateur avoir un 7 d'or pour
ses élégants n'arriverait jamais un jour
si un jour on remet les huit d'or vous
aurez huit d'or en effet donc pour une
assoc s'exclamant croyez vous êtes
invités de l'image parfois je me
rappelais plus importants et challes oui
on vous aime comme un mets mon sens il
ya des personnes qui sont là avec deux
qui en vaut une autre en valais on
regarde
[Applaudissements]
nos yeux mais il n'y a qu'un seul
vainqueur à cette soirée 17 d'or c'est
d'abord dans cinq ans
super souvenir ça c'est des débuts
fracassants
ah ouais ça dure j'adore ce qu'on peut
demander à la maquilleuse devenir
raccorder isabelle parce que c'est très
ambitieux c'est à fond c'est pourquoi
s'arrêter les 7 d'or c'est au moment où
vous étiez en train de percer et les
organisateurs se sont tues tu te rends
bien compte que chaque année
[Applaudissements]
oh
si la tension michael c'est avoue josé a
fait une course en caisse à savon en
2018 pour représenter l'association
rêves de gosse on va voir le début de la
vidéo et tu vas devoir deviner ce qui se
passe ensuite les bus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui va se passer
à quelques mètres de l'arrivée ils ont
eu un accident et la voiture s'est cassé
bravo c'est une bonne fête de la voile
[Rires]
content quand même
il ya tellement lu par branchement et
ouais en fait cela suggère faible enfin
on a chopé deux personnes -deux il y
avait deux cadreurs et on les a attrapés
en même temps et en fait on avait des
arts bacs dès le mien en fait moi
j'étais accroché donc ici c'est horrible
parce que j'ai tapé d'abord et après
quand les pompiers sont arrivés ils ont
enlevé le truc qui s'est déclenchée qui
m'ont dit monsieur garcia ça va j'ai dit
ah non je suis super mal amy sarah vous
aviez un airbag bientôt voit la tête et
bien tous mais je les aime et adore les
sports extrêmes
sa grand spécialiste des sports extrêmes
grand spécialiste en sicile et huppée du
fait de la non adhésion sicile comme les
sports extrêmes fait de l'avion tout cas
jean michel jarre dire vous êtes celui
qui bossaient plus assurément vous à une
petit enfin bravo jean michel prenez-en
de la graine avec ramdani vous y êtes à
côté lui copié sur lui on a droit à deux
chiffres au nom alors là la france
lassée en or donc ça veut dire que ça y
est on est à l'abri pour les abris
brestois c'est bon je le comprends vous
inquiétez pas on ne s'est pas compliqué
on aura le numéro de l'un de vous deux à
la fin de cette séquence
josé à vous écoutez bien ce titre de
mika ue ils sont rattrapés
à cent mille près combien miquel at il
vendu d'exemplaires du titre station à
100 milles près j'y vois un single
manquerait alors je dirais
neuf cent mille plus ses missions et ses
800 mhz issue pourrait concéder le titre
at&t partie dédiée plus grosses ventes
de singles du 21e siècle il est 8e du
classement
on en a vendu plus que ça et oui à mon
avis vous adapter les réponses non non
non vraiment la fiche la seule huit
matches et en a vendu combien c'est moi
c'est vous êtes vous fait pas fait
partie du pied de quelle association
merci trois missions allait bien quand
même un numéro à temps mais bon je suis
d'accord se vérifie s'il mérite quand
même un numéro je suis d'accord ça
mérite un numéro pour la nasa lance
l'insolence dans une séquence mythique
de nulle part ailleurs josé en canette
josé antoine était déguisé en moine on
se rappelle louis josé a eu la surprise
de boire un verre d'alcool pur qui était
l'invité de l'émission ce jour là
frédéric dard mais allez y connais rien
mais je l'attendais centre et d'héritage
bonnes réponses je disais donc que votre
se déroule par équipes dans une maison
de talleyrand ça je m'en excuse
oui bon père que 120 0
[Rires]
reggae binaire didot technique
oui je vous le vrai
c'est facile sécu pour l'instant donc ce
qu'il a donné à la grippe on dirait que
c'est toi c'est le numéro de jose on me
dit qui s'affichera josé nous allons
regarder le début d'une séquence de
michael qui une fois n'est pas coutume
dans moi le mien vous j'adore mais
nickel un peu tout nu voilà regardez
vous à nous dire la suède d'autres trucs
à dos rond mais là c'était pour le
cliché pas ça fait de sueur honteux
s'accroît il a raison c'est vrai
regardez jeu
m
[Musique]
alors que va-t-il se passer dans la
suite de la vidéo michael va se mettre à
danser
lire le journal ou faire un hélicoptère
lire le journal
ouais on regarde
[Musique]
remarquez la taille de la feuille de vie
elle est quand même assez petit
parce que dans ces moments là on n'en
mène pas large non mais ça c'était un
grand moment ça franchement gros moment
tu l'as fait tout aussi un abonnement
dans la rue ah bah oui officie dans la
rue la comédie bah ouais mais ça c'est
nouveau c'est au tour n'avait rien à
faire en soutane supermarché n'est pas
de scénario ou 10 à lyon 10 va donc ça
fait 2-2 michael à vous j'osais était
invité sur le plateau du grand journal
par antoine de caunes la retrouver
django edwards et tous les trois ont mis
un bordel incroyable sur le plateau en
quelle année c'était et ben moi j'ai pas
une question à choix multiples si 2011
2013 la vente est récent j'aurais bien
voulu et aider ça fait déjà six fois que
je change d'excusés mois 2011
malheureusement je vous le dis je vous
donnerai la réponse après après quoi
après l'extrait
[Musique]
m
à
k
[Applaudissements]
à
alors attention on me dit josé c'est
vous malheureusement qui avait perdu
pour toi unique parce que c'était parce
que c'est comme ça s'est décidé à sion
d'affection numéro fossé sachez tous les
téléspectateurs
allez c'est parti le numéro de jose pas
sa fille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'autres encore ça n'a pas l'air
ce
car finalement david o
où il est
[Musique]